[Music]
so you've tried your hand at all the
respectable ways to make a living the
part-time job the side hustle the
nine-to-five office job but nothing
seems to be working the pay sucks your
employers will never let you get ahead
and you're stuck in a perpetual rat race
a mediocrity it feels like there's no
way out
well if you're in need of cash and
exhausted all the legal ways to get it
maybe it's time to get a little more
illicit i mean creative now sure you
could turn to a life of petty crime pit
pocketing selling drugs or catfishing
people into sending you money but that's
all just so unsophisticated you could
rob a bank or jewelry store but you will
need months of planning a crew a whole
lot of guns
and not everyone has the time expertise
or money to get any of those things
plus robbing jewelry and banks is kind
of lower class kind of beneath you but
what if we stole art think about it i am
instead of having to pack dozens of bags
full of heavy cash or go in guns blazing
into a jewelry store what if you could
commit an elegant quiet crime where one
piece of canvas could be worth millions
upon millions of dollars it's a billion
dollar industry and most museums don't
have the money for the kind of security
that could keep you out so why not our
prices are skyrocketing more than 8 000
pieces of arts are stolen from italy
alone each year and out of the thousands
of art thieves out there only 1.5
percent are ever really caught and
prosecuted
so unlike other rackets the odds are
very much in your favor seriously art is
so easy to steal that one piece by
edvard monk called the scream was stolen
twice in just 15 years and recently sold
for 120 million dollars more than you
could ever get from a simple bank or
jewel heist art museums and exhibits are
basically sitting ducks
so obviously becoming a career art thief
is the only right move for someone of
your caliber so let's learn how to rob
fine arts theoretically of course please
don't steal stuff
you both recognize that i'm the best and
i'll tell you my secret
[Music]
all jokes aside we live in a beautiful
age where it's never been easier to make
a lot of money without risking going to
prison and the only thing you need to
make a lot of money is an internet
connection and a desire to learn that's
where brilliant comes in brilliant is a
website and app that offers fun
interactive courses in all things
science technology engineering and math
so you can take advantage of all the
opportunities that information age
offers data science the average data
scientist makes 117 000 a year and
brilliant has a learning path for it
that walks you through all the
fundamentals you need to know for data
science quantitative analysts they make
a hundred and twelve thousand dollars a
year on average and brilliant has a
learning path for that computer
scientists they make a hundred and six
thousand dollars on average and again
brilliant has a learning path on it to
give you a solid foundation on the
subject with courses on algorithm
fundamentals an introduction to neural
networks and even one on quantum
computing what makes brilliant different
from everything else is that it's built
off of a very simple principle you learn
best while doing not through lectures
repetition or doing odd number exercises
in a textbook that's why with brilliant
you get to jump right into solving
problems while being coached bit by bit
until before you even realize it you've
learned a fundamental concept in stem
you get instant feedback along the way
so you can improve as fast as possible
and there aren't any tests or grades
either just pick a topic you're curious
about and get started we live in the
easiest time in human history to make
money but the only way you're going to
do that is with self-education and to
get you started brilliant is giving you
guys 20 off when you go to brilliant.org
jake tran with the link below that's
brilliant.org trying to sign up for free
and get 20 off thanks to brilliant for
sponsoring this video
[Music]
now most people wouldn't be able to tell
the difference between an expensive
modern art piece and their kids art
projects no seriously take a look at
these two paintings and tell me which
one is worth millions and which one
should be stuck on your parents
refrigerator
believe it or not the first painting is
a piece by side twimly whose pieces
often sell for more than two million
dollars the second one is a
preschooler's attempt at painting with a
ball art theft is a niche get rich quick
scheme in order to succeed you need to
know your stuff run in the right circles
and be able to spot a fake within
seconds again i'm not joking so many
original art pieces have been stolen and
replaced with fakes you may be risking
years in jail for a worthless piece of
paper and since it's so niche it may be
wise to find a buyer who's ready to pay
big money for a specific piece and then
you source that piece so get out there
and educate yourself learn everything
there is to know about the art you want
to steal and remember you're robbing for
the money not the thrill so go for
something achievable and leave the mona
lisa alone
[Music]
art is difficult to sell the more famous
the piece is the more likely it is that
cops will be looking for it and that
you'll get caught trying to sell what
you stolen vincenzo perucha worked at
the louvre museum in paris in 1911
and actually did steal the mona lisa he
kept it hidden for two years before
trying to return it to an italian
gallery in exchange for a reward he was
immediately reported arrested and sent
to jail so give yourself the best chance
at actually stealing and selling the art
you're targeting by choosing a lesser
known piece that is still worth good
money like saitwombly's arts no one is
gonna launch an international manhunt
for any of those paintings some of the
best places to steal art are from
churches and small museums not only do
they have less security than a gallery
or museum like the metropolitan museum
of art in new york city but people are
less likely to notice if an art piece
just randomly disappears often staff
miscommunication at small locations like
those means that people think the art
was sent out for a restoration or
something in vincenzo peru chess case it
took a museum staff two days to realize
the mona lisa was missing but then again
it was the early 1900s so once you found
the right target and you know exactly
what you're gonna steal it's time to get
some help from the inside
[Music]
millionaires and billionaires may own
arts but the average museum worker is no
millionaire in fact the average art
museum security guard only earns around
32 000 a year that usually means that
most of the staff in art galleries and
museums are in some kind of debts and
that's what you can use to your
advantage
you see 90 of art heists in america
alone were committed or held by an
insider someone who had access to the
arts and knew how well it was protected
in order to get in and out without being
seen or caught you're gonna need some
help so find a security guard janitor or
anyone with the right kind of access who
has a problem you can solve use your
inside connection to find out as much as
you can about the art piece the building
security and the habits of the other
staff members if you play your cards
right your inside connection may even be
able to switch off some cameras while
you're getting the job done once you've
found your inside man or woman it is
time for the next step
[Music]
it's time to visit your targets if it's
a church go during service times when
you can blend in if it's an art museum
go during lunch there will be fewer
people who can watch or notice you be
friendly but try not to approach anyone
directly especially the security they
will remember your face check for
cameras first both visible and hidden
ones oftentimes small museums and
galleries don't have the money for a
massive camera network so a few of the
cameras may be fake no matter how
complicated the security there's no
amount of tech that can completely stop
a heist there's always a switch you can
turn off or a camera you can disconnect
once you've identified all the cameras
take a mental note of how many visitors
and staff are around is there security
in the target room are the security
guards sitting or standing what type of
floor does the building have wooden
floors are the best because you can hear
the creaking from far away carpets are
the worst memorize every exit before you
leave if you can plan your heist for a
day when the cameras are being repaired
or updated so that they may be off for a
few minutes use your insider to find out
what the protocol is when a thief is
discovered and make sure you pay
attention to any sensors or defense
measures put in place to keep the art
safe now that you have a lay of the land
it's time for the next step
[Music]
hollywood movies make it seem like
raffling into a museum from the roof in
the middle of the night is the best way
to steal arts but that couldn't be
further from the truth breaking into a
museum at night is a guaranteed way to
trigger the alarm stealing art in broad
daylight although much more of an
adrenaline rush is objectively safer in
most cases our thieves just walk in cut
the painting out of the frame and walk
right out without anyone noticing until
it's too late very few museums in the
world have the laser beams and sensors
you see in the movies so often the
simplest plan is the best a stylish
outfit with a slightly oversized jacket
and a swiss army knife stuck in your
pocket may be all you need if you want
to make extra sure you can get away
replacing the stolen art with a fake
even a bad fake could buy you at least a
few extra hours now that you've got a
plan and you've got the equipment you
need you're ready to go
[Music]
one of the world's most famous art
thieves stefan brightweiser would steal
from museums in broad daylights stuffing
whatever he took into his pants or under
his jacket as he calmly walked out of
the museum if you want to succeed you
don't have to reinvent the wheel walk
into the museum or church just as camera
repair starts or get your insider to
switch the cameras off calmly make your
way to where your art piece is waiting
often you can kill time waiting for the
room to empty by pretending to admire
the pieces around it once the room
empties you can get to work if the art
is under a display case the screwdrivers
in the swiss army knife will come in
handy if it's hanging on a wall
carefully cut it out of his frame and
replace it with your fake even if the
forgery is a cheap printout from far
away it will still look believable and
that's all you need
carefully place a stolen art piece under
your jacket or in your pants and make
your way to the nearest exit keeping
your head down you may have minutes you
may have hours to get away whatever the
getaway time follow the rules of the
road
[Music]
assuming you get away bleach or torture
a car destroy the fake place you should
have put on it and make it safely back
home the best thing to do is to get rid
of your loot as soon as possible by luck
people may take a day or two to notice
the real art is missing so you have a
very small window to offload your stolen
goods before the cops get involved which
brings us to the hardest part of
stealing arts the sale
best case scenario you were commissioned
by some millionaire art collector who
already agreed to pay you as soon as you
bring them the goods you're never going
to get the full amount of what the r is
worth but this is your best option for
making a good percentage if you stole a
painting worth 2 million dollars you
could probably get 1 million if you're
lucky another option is to ransom it
back to the insurance company or gallery
if you stole from some rich collector
you could get 20 to 30 percent of the
value to return the arts and avoid
getting the cops involved if you didn't
have a buyer beforehand and you stole
from a small gallery without a
millionaire backer you're gonna have to
lay low for a while our thieves hang on
to the stuff they stolen for years
before ever trying to sell it once
things cool down you have a few options
you could try to sell it legitimately
the best way to do this would be to look
for a buyer outside of the country you
stole from so if you stole something in
europe consider selling it in the us and
vice versa it's not foolproof but it
will give you a better shot of not
running into an undercover interpol or
fbi agents looking for the stuff you
stole if you get it right you can make
80 to 100 of the arts value in cold hard
cash if you're not interested in the
gamble of selling it openly your next
best bet would be the black markets here
you can find anyone from gang lords
looking for art to use as bargaining
chips and get out jail free cards to
genuinely interested collectors who
don't mind the fact that the art was
stolen best case scenario though is you
make 10 of what the art is worth if you
stole a 2 million painting you could
walk away with two hundred thousand
dollars sure it didn't turn you into an
instant millionaire but considering how
easy and addictive the thrill of art
theft can get you may feel up for a
second third fourth or even fifth heist
just as long as you never hit the same
place twice never let your guard down
and remember to pay your insiders
and if you like controversial mini
documentaries like this you're in luck
because every month we put out a
feature-length 40-minute plus
documentary on how the world really
works and how to profit from it that are
far too controversial to post publicly
on youtube that means these
documentaries will never be available
anywhere else we already have one
documentary out on monsanto the company
that owns the world's food supply and
rumor has it that next month the
documentary will probably be on our
friend whose first name starts for the j
and last name starts with e you can
preview all the documentaries out at the
time without being signed up with this
link below and all you have to do to get
this insider information is to click the
join button below right next to the
subscribe button or use the link below
if you don't see the join button and
you'll get access to this knowledge that
you will never get in business school
not for 55 to 161 thousand dollars but
for just five dollars a month and don't
worry if you join and don't feel like
it's worth it email me and i will
personally refund you the money click
that join button below now
[Music]
you